and these black troops who had their
lives on the line for a country which
rejected them between wars this story
was not getting out there
I am Nikolas be with reason TV and today
I'm sitting down with Jerome to Chile
he's best known for books like it
usually begins with I ran the first
biography of Donald Trump his latest
book is the roughest riders the untold
story of the black soldiers in the
spanish-american war Jerry thanks for
talking reason my pleasure this is a
fascinating book that as I was reading
it both made me proud and profoundly sad
to be an American it's about race
relations as they affected black
soldiers from the post-civil war era on
talk about the Buffalo Soldiers who are
at the center of this book who were the
Buffalo Soldiers the Buffalo Soldiers
were essentially freed slaves after 1863
who were free and named only they had no
access to the economy they could not get
jobs so most of them joined the army in
the early 1890s they wound up fighting
Indians out west and they got the name
Buffalo Soldiers from the Cheyenne and a
couple of other tribes who said that
they fought like Buffalo you know they
shot them full of arrows and they still
wouldn't die and of course their
appearance with the the shaggy Mane's
and the dark skin and so on said they
looked like Buffalo so the name stuck
and it came and these guys the
spanish-american war which famously
features Teddy Roosevelt he leading the
Rough Riders up San Juan Hill and we
talk about that in a second you know
this became the first kind of modern war
for American troops to be involved in
how did the Buffalo Soldiers end up
fighting and in the spanish-american war
well after the Indian Wars they came
back and America loved them and they
were fodder for the wars but then I had
these armed blacks in their modern
society and white people resented them
they were afraid of it you know these on
blacks uprisings and so on so at the
time Teddy Roosevelt was agitating after
the sinking of the Maine and Havana
Harbor to go down and take on the
Spanish even there was no proof that the
Spanish sunk the main in fact later
technology indicated it was probably an
internal like boiler room accident
exactly the thinking in Washington was
that the blacks would be better able to
withstand the tropical climate in places
like Cuba because of their genetic
makeup so the big battle in the
spanish-american war which really kind
of created a modern year the first big
step of American Empire because we ended
up winning against Spain and we ended up
with the Philippines as well as Cuba and
Puerto Rico and whatnot the most famous
battle is Teddy Roosevelt charging up
with the Rough Riders up San Juan Hill
that's the received history of it talked
a lot of what the book is about is how
that is just completely balderdash what
really happened on San Juan Hill well
it's felt nonsense actually Teddy
Roosevelt was covered by a bunch of
reporters who follow them around and
their job is to promote him and his
image and when he did that he gave them
access so they were in his camp received
images that there was a hill in Cuba
called San Juan Hill and Teddy Roosevelt
and his Rough Riders who were basically
Cowboys and a few Eastern Blue Bloods
looking for adventure charged up there
and chased the Spanish off well when you
start delving into the story you realize
that there were 10,000 Spanish soldiers
in the area at the time the Rough Riders
had about 500 total to start with and I
said of reading this and my [ __ ]
antenna stood at the quiver I said how
could this have happened the reality was
is that San Juan Hill was the last hill
to be taken there there were four hills
that were fought the first was called la
soie Simas named after some trees in the
area and Roosevelt was part of that
charge up there with 500 Buffalo
Soldiers and there was a column of white
regulars and black regulars on his right
and Roosevelt walked right into an
ambush and that first battle and lost
probably about a third of his men so out
of the 500 he's got 350 left now and the
blacks came over and rescued him along
with some white regulars and took the
hill from the Spanish less glossy of us
and after that there was a week delay
while we fully landed troops off the
boats
had come in off the harbour down there
Santiago Harbor and there were three
other hills to be taken the northernmost
was a place called el carne and it was a
town up on a hill and that was taken by
a combination of white Regulus and black
regulars the blacks get up there first
there was a long gruelling ten-day war
that the blacks get up there implanted
their guidon simultaneously there with
three hills over in the San Juan Heights
there was kettle Hill slightly to the
north of San Juan Hill and then there
was an Juan Hill itself and Roosevelt's
Rough Riders were assigned to kettle
Hill and he was getting wiped out the
Spanish had superior weaponry they had
these smokeless mousers that gave off no
smoke when they when it was fired and we
had these antiquated the smoke emitting
mitting means it's easier for soldiers
fighting you to see where you are and
point in the general they're right we
couldn't see with Hispanic were because
but they knew exactly where we were
because every time they fired a weapon
it was a target right Roosevelt and his
uh was assigned to kettle Hill much to
his chagrin because the main target was
going to be San Juan Hill as they were
going up kettle Hill Roosevelt men were
being decimated and he was down to about
50 soldiers Roosevelt himself was one of
the few with it with a horse which got
snagged and bobbed wire up there so he
was forced to get out it was a steep
incline these Cowboys were not
infantryman they were not soldiers and
the eastern blue bloods were not in
great shape either a contingent there
were four regiments of Buffalo Soldiers
down there actually went up and got up
to the top of kettle Hill first and
planted another guy Don buffalo soldier
guy Don up there and before Roosevelt
could get out he admitted later that the
thanks to the blacks and their military
acumen and so on they they saved the day
and they were great warriors and so on
there was another battle taking place on
San Juan Hill and they the people at the
top of kettle Hill which included
Roosevelt and is remaining Rough Riders
at this point can see the action over
there the black Buffalo Soldiers charged
down from cattle Hill and there was
another
of black soldiers buffalo soldiers some
of them will live by Pershing a
blackjack Pershing said who was called
blackjack he was rare for he would
openly admire and kind of praised black
soldiers ability he did he considered
them to be motivated and patriotic and
have great fighting ability and they get
up to the top of San Juan Hill as the
the troops the black people black troops
from kettle Hill and Roosevelt try to
get up there they the Buffalo Soldiers
had actually gotten there first and
planted another one of their guide ions
up there and the white regulars were
right there with them Roosevelt did not
get up to the top of San Juan Hill until
the fighting was over but of course
waiting up there were these a six
hand-picked reporters one of whom was
Stephen Crane who was the most
independent of them all because he was
famous for having written Red Badge of
Courage and of course they gave him me
the big reception and Roosevelt's
straggled up there with just a handful
of the remaining Rough Riders but the
cameras were focused on him he was great
copy the media loved him because he was
a colorful character an adventurer etc
and then he rode a kind of definitive
account of the spanish-american war in
which he was the starring soldier he did
of course he wrote a book called the
Rough Riders in the book he admitted
that the Buffalo Soldiers were you know
great warriors and and couldn't have won
without them but then later on he said
at the backpedal from that yeah and let
me talk about that because in in one of
the chapters you talk you say and I'm
quoting from you later
Roosevelt softened his praise saying he
had started out saying the black
soldiers were an excellent breed of
Yankee fighters then he was like now
they're about as good as a typical
American a white set of soldiers and
then finally he said that they only
performed their duties well because they
were peculiarly dependent on their white
officers and then finally he came to a
point where he was saying and this is a
Theodore Roosevelt boat Negro troops
were shirkers in their duties and would
only go so far as they were led by white
officers right what was what was
asserting itself there if the story got
out and it was one reporter
fella named cash-in who was the only one
assigned to cover the the Buffalo
Soldiers word got out that they were the
real victors there and so on it would
diminish Roosevelt's glory and and
that's what he was all about with
self-empowerment and so he started to
backpedal and claim that they only did
as well as they did because they had
white offices well of course they
weren't allowed to have black offices
and then later on he races 'm totally
took over when he when he said they were
shirkers and he had to pull his gun to
keep some of them from moving
you know heading back down the hill
which was a total fabrication
so it was Roosevelt preserving his image
and not allowing anybody else to share
any of the glory what is your goal in
writing a book like the roughest riders
my goal is I see a story which strikes
me as total nonsense and then reading
between the lines and really this
footnote in history about the role of
the Buffalo Soldiers has remained that
for the most part I mean there have been
a few other books Gayle Buckley I wrote
a book called American patriots but
there's a chapter on the Buffalo
Soldiers and a few others but it was all
piecemeal out there I mean the research
in this book was a killer for me it
probably lasted about a better part of
four or five years but I read everything
ever written about it I had a Library of
Congress material helped from the
National Park Service and the Rangers
who in charge of the Buffalo Soldier
project so I got all the stuff together
and I realized that this is an American
story which has been buried and these
black troops who had their lives on the
line for a country which rejected them
between Wars we're getting this story
was not getting out there and nobody
else was writing it so I just decided to
go and plunge ahead and do it myself do
you think that you know in many ways was
Harry Truman who integrated the troops
for the Korean War somebody like :
Powell who I think graduated college an
ROTC in 1959 became the you know
Secretary of State
blacks at least in the military have
they reached parity with whites well I
think they have today and Powell himself
said that he never really suffered from
a lot of discrimination he was a
light-skinned black and people are up
familiar with a lot of white culture and
so on so he personally did not see a lot
of that racism exists in his society and
I'm sure that even blacks in the
military today when it's integrated
experience it to a great extent as you
mentioned Harry Truman with an executive
order in 1948 ordered the military to be
integrated but even after that it took
quite a few years for to fully happen
during World War two by previous to that
of course that we had black units
segregated from the whites
I think racism is prevalent in this
society even today and I look I have
grandchildren three who range in age
from 10 to almost 14 and I think of them
as maybe the the first colorblind
generation in this country and they they
all have friends who are Asian black and
so on and I don't even think in those
terms whether that's true nationally or
not I don't know but I I think that's a
hopeful sign out there well hopefully
your grandchildren and mine will read
the roughest riders and remember where
they're coming from and how bad things
could be and how much better things can
be so thank you Jerry to Chile the book
is the roughest riders the untold story
of the black soldiers in the
spanish-american war for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie
you